cet endroit a l'air bien différent de
celui où nous sommes arrivés pendant
l'évacuation il le nettoie il y a encore
beaucoup de travail à faire avec tous
les véhicules tout l'armement toutes les
munitions qui ont été abandonnés par les
forces américaines et leurs alliés lors
de leur retraite quant au fils barbelés
il y en avait plusieurs murs parfois
aussi aucune personne c'est toujours en
cours de démantèlement mais comme je les
dis il y a encore beaucoup de travail
cette évacuation que le pentagone a
qualifié de la plus grande et la plus
complexe de l'histoire a laissé derrière
elle un tas de déchets d'épaves et de
débris nous dit ce lieutenant des
talibans ils ont détruit 95% de
l'équipement du matériel et des systèmes
ils ont tout détruit les véhicules les
avions surtout les habits militaires qui
ont été quant à eux détruit à 100% nous
avons demandé à voir l'aéroport et après
être monté dans une camionnette dans
notre voeu a été exaucé c'était comme un
plateau de cinéma pour une scène
apocalyptique
notre premier arrêt fût le cimetière
d'hélicoptères nom des hélicoptères et
il y en a beaucoup abandonnée dans
l'aéroport de kaboul ont été sabotés
assez visiblement les câbles ont été
coupés les différents blocs électriques
retirer et écraser apparemment avec une
masse tout ce que les talibans même les
avions pouvaient utiliser les américains
l'ont détruit et ceux qui n'ont pas pu
détruire ils l'ont laissé tomber
voici des caches pour chiens qui ont
provoqué une grande polémique en ligne
nous avons appris que oui beaucoup de
chiens ont été abandonnés par les
militaires américains mais ils ne sont
pas restés enfermés dans les cages comme
on nous l'avait fait croire ils ont été
relâchés semble-t-il avant le départ
définitif des troupes américaines
quelqu'un a ouvert toutes ses cages et
il aura laissé de la nourriture sur
internet les défenseurs des animaux se
sont mobilisés par milliers il
s'indignait que les troupes américaines
aient pu abandonner ses chiens juste là
à côté des pistes à la merci des
talibans
les américains ont laissé sortir les
chiens
mais nos équipes et nous représentons
officiel s'en occupe désormais
il essaie de les rassembler et de créer
toutes les conditions nécessaires à
leurs besoins
qu'ils soient en sécurité
c'est peut-être exactement ce dont les
taliban ont besoin une bonne campagne
médiatique rassembler les chiens les
remettre aux activistes et récolter les
lauriers humanitaire
d'un autre côté ils ont déjà beaucoup de
pain sur la planche les américains ne se
sont pas contentés de détruire les
véhicules ils ont saccagé bien plus que
cela
quand je suis arrivée à l'aéroport dans
la matinée j ai vu beaucoup de
destructions
beaucoup de choses ont été saccagés je
ne sais pas qui a fait ça mais dans les
faits les américains étaient là le
département des ressources en eau que
vous voyez derrière moi a été endommagé
mais par la grâce d'allah nous avons
réussi nous l'avons réparer
une autre chose intéressante dans
l'aéroport ce sont les centaines de
véhicules diplomatiques blindés
abandonnés au cours de l'évacuation ils
ont utilisé ces mêmes véhicules pour
bloquer les routes pendant l'évacuation
voici le contrôle des passeports à
l'aéroport international de kaboul le
voici tel qu'il a été abandonné une fois
l'évacuation terminé pour une raison
indéterminée outre la destruction de
tous les véhicules et avions militaires
que les états unis ont abandonné ils ont
également anéanti une grande partie de
l'infrastructure civile de l'aéroport
ordinateur scanner corporel caméra et
même les écrans d'arrivée et de départ
dit on les américains ont coupé les
câbles électriques renversés les écrans
brisé des fenêtres enfoncer les portes
et même piller les distributeurs
automatiques
pourquoi c'était peut-être l'ennui
peut-être la haine on ne sort pas d'une
guerre de 20 ans qui se conclut par une
évacuation humiliante sans ressentir un
peu de rancoeur